Speaker 1: . We have a voicemail
number and that number is 2192. David P
I did this story yesterday about how Jordan
Peterson attacked me for a video I did about
him. I got a voicemail about that. Let's listen
to the voicemail, then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 3: Hey, David Dale from Denver. Again,
just calling regarding the Jordan Peterson
clip you put on YouTube. Yes. The question
I would ask Dr. Peterson is. You think it's
bad to demoralize them by telling them the
truth and the reality of what's going on?
But is that actually better to lie to him about
that than it is to tell them the truth so they can
face the truth and maybe come up with a solution?
Speaker 1: Yeah. I mean, listen, this is basically
the point I made. Jordan Peterson wept because
he felt today's youth are being demoralized
and their lives are being ruined by being told
as humans, we're up against some hard problems.
And one of those problems is climate change caused
by industrialization, burning of fossil fuels and
human activity on planet Earth. Jordan Peterson
says it's demoralizing to tell young people that,
and they're almost being told. Peterson
claims that they are morally bad because
these are problems that we're facing. My view
is it would be immoral not to tell them that
if we want to solve these problems to some degree,
young people are going to be the people that,
when they are not so young, are going to be
in a position hopefully to solve some of the
problems that we're dealing with. If we hide
the fact that these problems exist from them,
how are we doing them? A service, we're doing
them a disservice, I would argue. And that's
I believe that's what the caller is arguing here
as well. I agree with the caller. I disagree with
Jordan Peterson. Jordan Peterson, as I told you
yesterday after flipping out on me, said that an
overweight woman is ugly and then quit Twitter. So
it was a wild week on Twitter for Jordan Peterson.
We have a great bonus show for you today. Here's
a fascinating study that was done. Americans who
do not currently have student loan debt were
asked, do you support Joe Biden forgiving the
student debt of people who do have debt? And
overwhelmingly those without student debt said,
yes, I still am in favor of that, but I don't
have student debt and I'm in favor of it. And I'll
explain to you why on the bonus show. Secondly,
U.S. soccer has agreed to an equal pay deal for
the men's and women's players. Very interesting.
We'll talk about it. And there's a lot to discuss
related to it. And for those of you who remember
Martin Shkreli, Martin Shkreli is this sort of a
dark figure who is mostly known for buying a
pharmaceutical company and then exploding the
cost of the drug that the pharmaceutical company
manufactures? He actually was just released from
prison, not related to that, but related to
some financial crimes that he was convicted of.
He has now been released from prison. And we
will talk about the hero's welcome that he's
getting in some places. Not everywhere, though.
All of those stories on today's bonus show. Sign
up at join Pacman dot com to get instant access
and remember that on Monday Memorial Day, we'll
be doing a one day membership special, trying to
bring in as many new members in one day as we can.
If you'd like to be notified when
that membership discount is live,
just sign up for my newsletter. The newsletter
is free at David Pakman dot com and you'll hear
from me on Memorial Day with very specific
instructions. And of course, everybody who
signs up gets access to the bonus show.
Speaker 3: Oh, the bonus show where you
want to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: Right. Okay. We'll see
everybody on the bonus show or tomorrow.